can't keep my hands to myself no matter
how hard I'm trying to I want you all to
myself your metaphorical Jenin Jew so
come on get me at a young age in
covering Selena Gomez's hands to myself
at the wedding he and wife Chrissy
Teigan through four get this their
daughter Lunas stuffed animals I don't
know how many of you have been to a
wedding between two stuffed animals but
what I found is that they are
everlasting making love to each other
and I'm trying I'm trying all of the
downs and the uppers keep making love to
each other and I'm trying trying trying
but I can't keep my hands to myself yeah
safe to say John and Chrissy committed
alright everybody thank you for
gathering here today on this very
special day
the Sun is high it's a beautiful day
well-deserved in what has become 26
weeks an incredible relationship who
dare gives this
lamb and sheep away
for rabbit
it's so much fun because there are baby
people and their toddler people there
are people that love a tiny little baby
but I need action
I need pay us I need them to talk back I
need them to I want to teach them
lessons and it's just it's so much fun
funny enough well John and Chrissie put
on their own performance Selena did the
same on her Instagram singing a worship
song with friends
[Music]